i think a lot of hosts are insecure and
they don't like people filling in for
them because they're afraid they're
going to lose
their job and uh you know you were not
insecure
you said let them let them have their
way
i would be happy to let them fill in for
me if i could get paid and not have to
to work at all that's my ideal scenario
if i could do this all year round that's
that's what i want to do most of the
celebrities probably won't even notice
it's not me on the other end of the
of the of the zoo who in your opinion
was the best at filling in for you i
will say
the best monologue i thought was given
by a guy named lil rel howery you know
lil rel
no he's an actor and a funny guy too
he's a
comic actor but he gave a very serious
not very serious but
emotional monologue and not
you know most everybody was there and
and they did jokes and
um and he was weird because the writers
were getting frustrated because he
didn't want to talk
he didn't want to go through jokes he
didn't want to go through anything he's
like ah no no no
and they just they thought he was
putting it off but then he showed up and
gave this great monologue
you weren't nervous that let's say lil
rel came in
and he was so good that abc gave you the
phone call and they said listen jimmy
we love you and everything you're a
great guy we we love your show you've
been doing great for us for 17 years now
but little rel was so [ __ ] good i
wouldn't be he's taking
happy with that yes that's
fine i'd have no idea if they said jimmy
whatever
jimmy we want little rel to do the show
and you can fill in for him when he
doesn't want it
you'd be happy with that